[Music]
right now how Oprah found a diet that
works the only thing I've not been
consistent in weight or hairdos Oprah
opened up to the New York Times Magazine
for this weekend's cover story called
losing it in the anti dine teenage she
tells the magazine quote I've tried all
of the green juices and protein shakes
and let's do a cleanse and all that
stuff that doesn't work it doesn't last
over also discusses the so-called body
positivity movement saying quote so all
the people who are saying oh I need to
accept myself as I am I can't accept
myself if I'm over 200 pounds because
it's too much work on my heart it causes
high blood pressure for me like
everybody I want to live a life that's
full full of the happiness found and
living the life I want the media mogul
who purchased a 10% stake in Weight
Watchers in 2015 says the key is
consistency and mindful eating but the
weight isn't Who I am
you know I am NOT a size and I am NOT a
number on a scale well Oprah something
up best as she does saying she doesn't
care if she's ever skinny again she just
wants control
you